bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale télé
spéciale grand champion de l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs avec jerome boehm ou fera 5
jérôme salle et stéphane alors on avoir
un champion extraordinaire encore
puisque il s'agit d'un double finaliste
du championnat du monde
et puis quelle est la caractéristique
aussi d'avoir une dimension politique
très importante lors de lors de sa
carrière il s'agit de victor correia
victor corse noé et oui natif de
leningrad et qui a une carrière d'une
exceptionnelle longévité puisque il né
en 1931 il a donc 80 ans et il est
toujours actif il joue encore au plus
haut niveau et bien et bien donc c'est
absolument exceptionnel parce que le
niveau de performance des croix
relativement rapidement à partir de 50
60 ans aux échecs quand même beaucoup de
champions qui ont plus ou moins arrêtés
lui a toujours continué et il a été
c'est quelqu'un qui était nourrie par le
combat dès l'enfance il était nourri par
le combat je reviendrai il a été aussi
nourri par son combat contre les
autorités soviétiques
c'est un dissident il a fini par partir
de l'union soviétique dans les années 70
pour s'installer en suisse et corning
c'est quelqu'un qui a besoin qui a
besoin d'ennemis c'est un peu un boxeur
il a besoin d'ennemis il a besoin
d'avoir des gens contre qui se
confrontaient pour vraiment trouvé dans
ses ressources dans ce combat là alors
son ou ses combats ils ont commencé très
jeune puisque il né en 1931 il naît dans
une famille dont les parents sont
séparés ce qui est
assez peu fréquent dans la société de
l'époque sa mère est une pianiste un peu
un peu excentrique d'après ce que
raconte l'histoire et son père lui un
métier plus plus tranquille mais ce
qu'il y ait dans l'ingénierie est il
d'origine d'origine polonaise
les parents sont séparés quand vient la
guerre y perd son père y perd aussi son
oncle et finalement il va se réfugier
chez sa grand mère maternelle qui elle
même d'origine d'origine polonaise mais
il va un petit peu ballotté comme ça et
il ya des gros problèmes à ce moment là
dans la vie de corchia parce que les
rations alimentaires sont très très
faible à tel point que quand sa grand
mère maternelle meurent pendant la
guerre il ne déclare pas aux autorités
avec un voisin une décide d'aller
enterrer discrètement le cadavre
continuer à toucher les rations c'est
assez terrible mais c'est la seule façon
qu'il a de de survivre donc faso face
aux épreuves de la vie il est obligé de
se battre c'est un survivant et il est
même atteint d'une maladie grave la
dystrophie l'a envoyé à l'hôpital et
filles est finie la période de la guerre
alors qu'il adolescents à l'hôpital
donc on comprend ensuite qu'il ait eu
une soif de vaincre une soif de se
battre qu'il a pu exprimer
dès les années 40 puisqu'il commence à
jouer aux échecs assez tardivement c'est
un joueur qui est arrivé relativement
tardivement échec
il obtient bien sûr de bons résultats
assez rapidement il est pris sous la
coupe de plusieurs entraîneurs et il
devient grand maître international
seulement à 25 ans je lis seulement à 25
ans parce que c'est c'est quand même pas
c'est quand même pas si précoce que ça
on a vu des gens très précoce comme un
fichier raw polgar qui ont été grands
maîtres à 15 ans et disons que en
moyenne la plupart des grands maîtres de
l'histoire ont déjà atteint un premier
pic de force aux alentours de 20 ans 25
ans c'est un tout petit peu tardif c'est
mal et corchia il sera va mettre du
temps à faire son affaire sont en
réalité bien sûr il commence à obtenir
des très bons résultats dans les
tournois et pendant toute la décennie
des années 60 il remporte de très
nombreux tournois mais surtout en europe
de l'est
bizarrement les autorités soviétiques ne
lui accordent déjà pas à cette période
là une très grande confiance
il est natif de leningrad c'est une
ville qui est que dont les
ressortissants sont connus pour être un
petit peu
et en dehors des turbulents et en dehors
du pouvoir central une tendance des
centrifugeuses les habitants des
migraines et simple à rebelles
apparemment c'est pas le seul essai pas
le premier mais je crois que
soljenitsyne aussi était de leningrad du
reste et les autorités des soviétiques
ils font pas beaucoup confiance qu'on
lui accorde pas de visa pour aller jouer
en europe de l'ouest et il fait tous les
grands tournois qui remporte en europe
de l'est
mais même quand il s'agit en 63
d'envoyer à santa monica aux états unis
pour la coupe qui étaient à bord ce qui
de joueurs on envoie petrossian et au
lieu d'envoyer corchia et on envoie la
fin de petrossian pour là pour
accompagner le champion donc une le vit
comme une vexation puisqu'il était censé
envoyer deux joueurs finalement on en
voit le meilleur joueur et sa femme donc
les lui reste en union soviétique
attendre que ça se passe il peut pas
participer à certaines grandes
compétitions occidental donc il se rend
compte à ce moment là qui est un petit
peu barré par les autorités soviétiques
font pas confiance c'est un franc-tireur
c'est un individualiste il est sans être
un grand rebelles s'est parlé
il est peu enclin à suivre la discipline
et la ligne du parti et dès ce moment là
les autorités soviétiques se méfie
fortement de lui d'accord mais aussi sur
des fils des autorités sous vitry
abbaoui lui aussi partagé c'est parti on
s'est partagé
à ceci près que lui les soldes alors que
les autorités soviétiques sont incarnés
par de multiples instances que ce soit
l'état la fédération mais aussi les
grands maîtres
puisque quand en 1974
car il atteint la finale du championnat
du monde en 1974 ou en tout cas la
finale des candidats finale des
candidats lambda et qui s'est avérée
ultérieurement finalement finale
championnat du monde puisque car pauvre
wenger de ceux de cette finale ne
rencontrera pas fichés donc c'était
quasiment une finale il le savait pas
s'il ne savait pas à ce moment là mais
en tout cas rétroactivement c'est apparu
comme étant une finale même si c'est
seulement une finale des candidats
karpov l'a pas emporté de beaucoup
d'ailleurs contre cornouaille à ce
moment là car peuvent surtout a fini
très très fatiguée physiquement parce
que c'était un match très très long et
karpov qui était plutôt d'une bonne
corpulence lui aimait bien ces combats
très très long donc ça l'avait peu
dérangé qui regardent encore jeune et
karpov qui était plutôt qu'ils étaient
plutôt frêle et qui était pas forcément
très fort physiquement a eu du mal à
terminer ce match mais l'a finalement
emporté cornouaille a ensuite donné une
interview à un journal yougoslave dans
lequel il s'est littéralement répandu en
disant que le match a été organisé dans
des conditions qui étaient qui lui était
très défavorable
en gros il y avait un petit peu voler
match et que les autorités soviétiques
avaient un petit peu spolier la réaction
des autorités soviétiques s'est pas fait
attendre
on a demandé à tous les grands maîtres
soviétique de prendre position contre
corps chemin ils me l'ont tous fait à
l'exception de bernstein de bronstein
quentin le champion des années 50 fameux
champion des années 50 et corchia est
apparu tel qu'il est est c'est à dire un
homme seul qui avait critiqué un régime
dans lequel malgré tout il vivait au
quotidien donc la situation de corchia
difficile bien sûr pas question pour lui
de pouvoir aussi vraiment qu'avance se
déplacer pas de possibilité de
participer aussi facilement à des
tournois des stages d'entraînement etc
donc il a dû vraiment se battre même à
ce moment là le le pic de cette période
de tension est atteint au moment où
quand je l'aï choisie a dit silence
voilà donc cesser ces moments clés de sa
de son coming-out politique en quelque
sorte on va beaucoup parler de lui du
coup
presque plus à cause de cette décidant
ce que pour ses énormes qualités de
champion d'échec puisque donc des 74 il
manque de très peu finalement la
possibilité de devenir champion du monde
et ça serait que le premier de ses trois
affrontements finalement avec art pop
funky oran a tenu le haut du pavé
pendant presque plus de 10 ans en fait
pendant quasiment une vraie une dizaine
de mails une dizaine d'années dans les
années 70 et au début des années 80
alors qu on y juge qu'il est temps pour
lui de quitter l'urss parce que
visiblement il est barré ou persona non
grata et lors d'un tournoi en suisse
il demande selon la légende il demande
au grand maître tony maïs comment on dit
asile politique en allemand et ensuite
il s'enfuit du tournoi et se précipite à
l'ambassade et demande l'asile politique
on dit que c'est une légende parce que
il semble étonnant à tout le monde qu
aucun grand maître soviétique n'ait
remarqué qu'ils demandaient comment
disait asile politique personne va que
plus personne n'ait remarqué la
manoeuvre peut-être que les grands
maîtres soviétique qui était présent un
petit peu fermé les yeux sur le fait que
corchia qui s'était enfui pour aller
vers l'ambassade
en définitive il s'installe en suisse il
va pouvoir continuer sa carrière
mais par contre de la mémoire des échecs
soviétique il est effacé jusque sur les
photos les autorités soviétiques sera
dans les revues d'échec est dans les
livres des chèques dans les
comptes-rendus tournois font disparaître
et le nom de cornouaille et sa photo
mais ça fout pas comme come on come dans
les années 30 sur les photos on faisait
disparaître trotsky et tout ce qui était
considéré par staline comme des ennemis
du régime
donc c'est véritablement devient à
partir de là par 176 un ennemi politique
alors que les soviétiques ont déjà dû
manger leur chapeau en 72 parce que ce
pass qui a perdu contre fischer le
championnat du monde
perdre le championnat du monde contre
les américains c'est une chose mais
l'idée que karpov l'enfant chéri du
régime puissent perdre contre un
dissident était tout simplement
inenvisageable pour les autorités
soviétiques 1 c il faut se remettre dans
le contexte de l'époque perdre contre un
américain c'est désagréable perdre
contre corchia il c'est impensable c'est
impensable
d'où là
extraordinaire tension qui va les voir
autour du match de 78 du championnat du
monde de baguio city aux philippines ou
karpov les corps jeunes vont se livrer
un affrontement qui dans un premier
temps tourne largement à l'avantagé de
karpov qui mène jusqu'à 5 à 1
mais korshunov en bon combatif et en bon
lutteur qu'il est revient à 5 2 puis 5 3
5 4
ça nous rappelle certains matches car
pauvre kasparov absolument fait partie
des petites à dire des faiblesses de
karpov mais c'est vrai que karpov sur le
long terme dans les matchs a toujours eu
des difficultés à finir à finir disco
plan physique ils étaient un petit peu
moins un petit peu moins fort que ses
adversaires lui a peur de perdre sarkozy
c'est peut-être aussi la peur de perdre
ou là la difficulté à apprendre à garder
l'initiative et et a joué pour le gain
quand on quand on mène 5 1 c'est
peut-être pas évident il a connu aussi
après contre kasparov puisqu'ils
menaient 5 0 il a jamais réussi à
marquer le sixième point en tout cas
corchia est revenu quasiment à égalité
et puis il a craqué dans la dernière
partie où karpov l'a finalement emporté
et a gardé le titre de champion du monde
ça c'était un enfant de dix-huit c'est
sans doute le moment ou encore jeune
homme mentalement le plus proche du
titre mondial oui il est il et deuxième
mondial au classement
en tout état de cause il ne manque pas
grand chose qui lui manque pas grand
chose mais il ne sera jamais aussi près
de ce titre qu'en 78 à nouveau il
dispute une finale à merano en italie
contre karpov en 81
mais la différence de niveau est devenu
un peu plus sensible entre les deux et
karpov ou l'emportant sans grande
difficulté sur une marque beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus largement conclut la suite
à quoi le carrière de cornouaille
continue il remporte encore des grands
tournois dans les années 80 à plus de 50
ans il ya 56 ans je prends 87 quand ils
gagnent d'al kanz et donc c est un garde
un niveau de performance est absolument
exceptionnel pour son argent parce que
les échecs ça a l'air calme mais comme
disent la plupart des champions delà de
40 ans et plus possible de faire jouer
au plus haut niveau
corchia une longévité absolument
exceptionnelle même dans les années
90 et même 2000 il a remporté je crois
le championnat du monde senior il ya
quelques années soixante dix huit ans ou
à peu près avec neuf points sur 11
donc c'est quelqu'un qui a maintenu un
niveau qui est équivalent à celui d'un
grand maître jusqu'à aujourd'hui encore
très récemment
je crois que c'était début août 2012 au
fin juillet 2012 il y a eu un match
entre le club de genève et puis
l'aigreur et les jeunes talents suisses
dont certains très grands joueurs très
forts joueurs comme yannick pelletier et
corchia il ya tenu son rang et même
mieux que ça il a remporté plus de parti
qui n'en a perdu donc même face à la
jeune garde
il est encore capable de se battre
exceptionnel hors à noter pour finir une
anecdote connu des amateurs français
pour ceux qui ont vécu dans les années
le trophée niveau par corneille avait
joué à ce moment là un match donc de ce
tournant c'est un tourneur de parties
rapides dans un d'interoute hôtel de
champs elysées à paris beaucoup de monde
dans la salle presque mais perd mille
spectateurs en ce moment la partie
fantastique match fantastique et en fait
les deux joueurs arrivent à égalité et
il ya ce qu'on appelait déjà à l'époque
les tie-breaks ses réparties en 8 pour
départager après les parties rapides et
la partie est extrêmement tendue ça va
très vite probablement que kornoi tient
la partie du lors comme il allait noir
ça lui donne donc en fait la victoire
match parce que celui qui allait finul
avec les normes gagne le gagner le match
mais il ya encore possibilité de jouer
donc ça joue et pièces vole un peu ça ça
va trop vite maintenant public on a du
mal à suivre et la pendule à ce moment
là tombe de la salle en moi j'étais dans
la salle donc j'ai vu ça
donc c'est tout à fait exceptionnel a
vendu le tournoi à savoir aujourd'hui me
paraît une pendule tomber surtout entre
des grands maîtres entre des jours ça
arrive des fois et
d'ailleurs suite à sa blanche shapira
qui est l'organisateur de cet événement
d'alain trio de champions avait décidé
de scotch et clariant a répondu que sur
la table pour éviter ça donc c'est
quelque chose qui est venu après n'avait
compris qu'il valait quand même
immobilisé la pendule donc attendu le
temps mais finalement on savait plus où
on en est parce qu on puisse y rester
très peu de temps deux joueurs qui
pouvaient tomber l'un ou l'autre
écornant il ya eu le geste de de dire à
l'arbitré qui lui demandait alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce que c'était
quand même partie nulle sur l'échiquier
plus ou moins etc
kasparov aux états unis sauf qu'il était
énervé aussi failli s'est énervé tous
les deux parce qu'il y avait et il court
chemin il n'a pas perdu trop de sang
froid et il a proposé de remettre la
partie et c'est une souche est d'autant
plus grand qu'il a perdu finalement donc
récemment fait passer et je me rappelle
très bien que lors de la remise des prix
en fête a eu plus d'applaudissements
pour corse noël que pour le vainqueur du
tournoi qui en l'occurrence était
kasparov
du fait de ce geste sportif bon kasparov
était pas en cause parce que ce n'est
pas lui qui a proposé d'enlever sa
partie c'est cornouaille mais son geste
est beau parce que silva il y avait
quand même une ambiguïté il a voulu ils
voulaient gagner il a toujours voulu une
année dans les règles en fait et il a
toujours été très populaire auprès des
amateurs d'échecs notamment en france
mais aussi à l'étranger parce que c'est
un dissident parce que c'est souvent été
un homme seul qui s'est souvent battu
seul ou à peu près contre une armada de
m soviétique et grand maître soviétique
parce que c'est un combattant parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui renonce pas et que
même la continuer à avoir un style assez
offensif et de déséquilibre c'est
quelqu'un qui joue pas un jeu très
orthodoxe et
et voilà c'est un vrai c'est un vrai
battant et il a une cote d'amour très
très élevé parmi les femmes d'échec et
un jour universel que jouent tous les
types d'ouverture ni sait tout jouer
donc on va voir quelques photos
maintenant de kornoi alors notamment une
photo tout à fait extraordinaire qu'on a
là puisque cette photo corchia et à
droite
voilà c'est l'homme qui sourient et à
gauche on a un autre champion du enfin
comment va pas été champion du monde on
a un ancien champion du monde qui est à
ce moment-là président de la fédération
internationale d'échecs c-max eux qui
est à gauche le champion hollandais des
années 30 celui qui avait battu et les
kin donc c'est quand même légende
vivante à ce moment là on la
photographie bien sûr et alors c'est pas
tout parce que sur le tableau si vous
distinguer correctement c'est quand même
extra puisqu'on a en fait la liste de
villes qui proposait d'organiser oui
j'imagine on imagine que c'est certain
le vermont c'est clairement qui est rien
imaginez donc qui proposait des magic
d'organiser pardon le championnat du
monde
des chèques entre cornol et rapport on
reconnaît d'ailleurs la ville de bac et
au de bayrou a été donné ce match en
avant dernier tout en bas philippines
baguio city et ya marqué en francs
suisses le montant du prix qui était
proposé pour la bourse du match 1
millions 105 millions 54 1350 c'est très
près voilà un million 54 1350 francs
suisses parce que c'était de donner en
double un art vivant quelques votre
devise donc il a fallu faire un lieu un
changement alors c'est intéressant de
voir ça parce qu'on voit les prix donnés
par les autres villes alors qu on est
encore soixante dix huit là oui
exactement donc en hollande qu'il dure
qui est une grande ville des échecs et
une plaine tournera-t-il bio propose un
million de son ami francs suisses et
après alors par contre on tombe à des
niveaux extrêmement bas à part en gros
ou encore hambourg et l'autriche qui
passe dans un million de francs suisses
haye à hambourg ou un bourg je le vois
pas un troisième en troisième malawi 1
million il ya aussi graz en autriche est
riche et apparemment un million aussi
ouais on a quand même des opprimés par
contre on a la france paris cent mille
plus les droits télé plus de la moitié
des droits jusqu'à -10° ça fait quand
même ça fait peur à côté et italie
150000 et la suisse 100 milles
ouais c'est pas sérieux non mais on a
quand même donc une
une palette de quatre villes entre le
graet hambourg une bulle des matières
sciatique qui proposait un million de
francs suisses ce sont des sommes très
importantes parce que ce je connais pas
le cours du franc suisse par rapport au
franc 1978 j'imagine que c'était de
l'ordre de 3 francs pour en francs
suisses soit quelque chose comme ça donc
on est sur à peu près 3 millions de
francs spam à 3 millions de francs à
l'époque on peut considérer que c'est
largement c'est bien ouais c'est
largement ça en euros maintenant c'est à
dire le double c'est une belle somme en
tout cas
voilà et puis bon c'est marrant de voir
cette photo extraordinaire nous sans
doute ils sont en train de discuter des
offres early dont ils vont prendre sans
doute les plus chers des d'ailleurs ces
maillots qui l'a emporté moi je
comprends qu'ils soient de bonne humeur
ont défini voilà donc ça c'est une
première photo quand même qu'il faut
qu'il faut avoir vu quand même vraiment
extra alors une autre photo ici de
cornouaille alors plus âgés en train ici
de t'appuyer sur sa pendule il veut
jouer son premier coup quand on voit que
il a joué d'ailleurs le coup s'est
classé 4 et jouent souvent la partie
anglaise il joue face aux grands maîtres
ses repères et on le voit avec le
drapeau suisse puisque il a eu un temps
pas de drapeau c'est vrai qu'elle était
privée de drapeaux il était apatride et
finalement il a pris la nationalité
suisse a alors encore une fois ici corse
noël en boîte par contre qu'ils jouent
ce qu'on appelle une simultanée parties
simultanées donc il est au milieu
voiliers de la reine est entourée des
tables et les joueurs sont face à lui en
en courant et en fait il va jouer les
coups en faisant le tour
enter les temps voit qu'il est beaucoup
plus âgée là ça doit être assez récent
son oui je crois que c'est une photo de
2006 ou quelque chose comme ça donc il
ya 80 et la remise en cause il a pas
loin de 80 ans il soit 75 ans mais
continue à donner une simultanée faut
savoir qu'une simultanée c'est plusieurs
souvent plusieurs heures d'efforts il
faut rester debout que j'imagine qu'il
faisait des pauses sont quand même il
faut quand même une certaine force
physique et au delà de la concentration
c'est une épreuve à votre avantage
physique que intellectuelle surtout pour
un homme de cet âge donc c'est assez
remarquable
ouais c'est presque
sur ce poste trop il faut d'accord et
troué comme une bonne solution pour le
porsche man is il a donc ici et on fait
une dernière image de corps en train de
ces en train de signature on voit on
voit les piles de livres saturin ça me
semble non
c'est oui je crois que cela turin 2 c en
2006 alors moi j'étais à thuré j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir partir de ce moment
là donc je peux raconter une petite
anecdote puisque j'étais allé pour voir
un peu c'est devenu une pièce je n'avais
jamais vu en fait donc j'ai visité un
peul et j'ai vu un peu les joueurs moi
je discutais etc et et j'ai pris
quelques photos et j'ai voulu prendre
photos en photo cornouaille qui au
moment de vous je commence à mettre le
doigt sur le déclic se lève et me vois
qui me prend en photo et il appelle
arbitre et il voulait pas absolument pas
qu'on le prenne en photo
donc j'ai essayé plusieurs fois pour
rigoler pour relier montre réglé je peux
appuyer
il faisait la tête moi je n'existe pas
quand même je vais pas à perturber la
légende en tant qu ancien ennemi du
régime soviétique
peut-être développé un certain une
certaine méfiance vis-à-vis de tout
moyen de communication on reviendra
peut-être au cours de notre discussion
sur la partie sur les conditions dans
lesquelles s'est déroulé le match de 78
qui était vraiment très particulière oui
parce que c'était à manille donc dans un
climat tropical avec avec des histoires
invraisemblables et rocambolesque de il
ya un docteur un parapsychologue qui
soutenait que karpov et plus les
cochonneries l'accuser d'essayer de lui
envoyer des mauvaises ondes le docteur
zuccarelli alors corchia il s'est
ensuite entouré d'un millier au gui à
lui pour essayer de repousser les
mauvaises ondes enfin on est on est dans
carrément vraiment dans la paranoïa la
plus pure et ce ne sera pas forcément
donné une extraordinaire images des
échecs mais en l'occurrence vous je me
souviens que le camp de cornouaille
aussi avait accusé karpov parce que
karpov se faisait servir un yaourt
à la même heure tous les jours et quand
je lui ai dit oui mais il ya un code
dans le yaourt s'ils ont leur steve ans
le parfum du yaourt ça veut dire quelque
chose voilà c'était c'est les conditions
de jeu étaient extrêmes on était à une
époque de grande tension ya eu plusieurs
championnats du monde où les où les
opposants les challengers ou les
champions ont pu accuser l'adversaire
d'avoir piqué des préparations appliquer
les recettes de jeu vont en fait via des
espions dans leurs équipes ou des des
manoeuvres de ce type là effectivement
réussi c'est ici noir effective qui est
qui était un peu c'était un peu c'est la
bière froide non mais c'est ça aussi
avec tous les films de james bond c'est
derrière ça on est on est pas loin de
l'univers parodique de james bond
quelques pas alors on va revenir sur le
plateau qui on va passer à un autre
parti du jour une partie évidemment de
victor kornoi et puis pas n'importe
quelle partie puisqu'on va regarder une
de ces victoires face aux grands anatoly
karpov lors du championnat du monde de
1978 donc ammann est issu un simple oui
à côté de baguio city mannix est donc
hors ici c'est 4 de la part de corse
noise c'est parti avec six cas laisser
3e 6 alors là donc les noirs choisissent
un développement du côté où là la flèche
qui part de travail à un développement
du côté qu'ici où est pour le fou on
continue avec un relief 3d 5 des quatre
fous aux 7000 pas lu jusqu'au bout il
est allé là donc ça s'est classé quand
on est dans une grande vie d'amy sicre
ainsi qu'un paravent chose à dire pour
l'instant
faut être quatre voilà ça c'est une
opportunité c'est bien ça permet de
développer le fou avant qu'on joue le 3
qui est utile puisque ça va permettre de
développer le fou de casques blancs de
contrôler ces quatre et six ont joué
trois tout de suite évidemment le
c'est à la maison on peut le faire mais
c'est une autre type de parti al
avantage de ce coup c'est qu'ils
attaquent une faiblesse du camp noir
dans le grand vide âme c'est le pion
c'est cette voie là ils attaquent aux
sept cases un an ceux qui ont souvent va
bouger plus tard mais mais la case reste
peut rester vulnérable on a le cavalier
c3 qui pourrait sauter en v5
pourquoi on à la tour 1 qui pourra aller
en c1 et quand la colonne s'ouvrira
après la prise du pion par exemple ça
peut être bien ça peut être une caisse
dans les yeux exactement
à noter aussi que évidemment c'est un
fou qui contrôle la case centrale 5
voilà alors on peut aussi sortir le
fonds enregistre un bon c'est autre
chose
il en a chaque fois chaque coup implique
d'autres types de démarches
ce qui compte c'est d'avoir une certaine
cohérence dans la démarche notion pas
mélanger trop les idées 1
alors ici donc petit rock et enfin voilà
trois tranquille et un karpov a refusé
de prendre le pion c'est alors on peut
toujours reprendre ce pion c'est à dire
que si ici au lieu de faire petit rock
les noirs avaient pris le pion c4 on
aurait pu jouer le simple dames à quatre
échecs dames prince et 4 et puis on
finira par soit aux trois semaines que
quatre puisque si le pion des disparus
ont peu joué aucun doute
donc pour éviter ce type de manoeuvre
bien on fait petit rock on ne prend pas
le pion et on joue ensuite ou 3 et là
c'est l'heure c'est simple c'est ce
qu'on vise alors c'est souvent une
manoeuvre comme on le voit c'est une
manade possible pour les blancs mais
c'est aussi une oeuvre aussi pour les
noirs dont l'idée c'est de se
débarrasser d'un pion de l'ale pour un
pion central ici le pion des 4 blanc qui
choisissent de reprendre et non pas de
laisser le loisir le loisir ou noir de
prendre les noms des quatre ce qui donne
d'autres types de parties faut prendre
ces 5
à noter qu'un ici que une des idées
aussi de prendre soi-même en danse et en
obligeant du nord de prendre c'est que
le fouet bouger deux fois il a joué de
fawcett est fou c'est simple c'est
quelque part ça peut être considéré
comme une perte de temps
tam ces deux jolies casse ou alors c'est
souvent une bonne gascon à damas
ces deux alors ça libère la potentialité
de jouer la tour en d1 avec un visa
vidal toujours le pénible et aussi
l'idée de jouer food étroit avec une
batterie fou dame qui tape sur h7
ça permet de gagner du temps souvent il
va falloir parfois joué j'ai 6 ou 6 pour
contrecarrer la puissance de cette
batterie
donc c'est une bonne très bonne case en
général ici pour la dame et en
particulier ici un petit point qu'on
peut ajouter l'oeuf ou c5 dans l'air il
n'est pas protégé et il suffirait que le
pion qui est emprise disparaisse et que
lecavalier se pousse lui aussi est la
dame pourrait porter une attaque sur ce
fou c'est 5 voilà il ya une famille ici
qui potentiellement en prison
cavalli c6 voilà que je touche mon cas a
laissé six tours d1 c'est ce qu'on avait
dit on a aussi libéré la case on l'a
tourné à noter un qui fait pas le grand
pourquoi pas le grand roque s'y risquer
un peu parce qu'on a bougé le pion sais
mais ça pourrait s'envisager
puisqu'après ont pour leur vendre des
reins en enfer rock c'est jouable
c'est jouable c'est sans doute
extrêmement tendue mais et c'est bien
qu'au risque on n'a pas trop envie de
mettre le roi là dans le côté où on a
finalement ouvert le jeu mais ça peut se
jouer ça peut s'envisager dans certaines
ouvertures tendue alors damas est qu on
veut éviter évidemment le vis-à-vis dam
tour toujours embêtant puisque les
menaces de prises ici se font avec une
tour qui qui gêne et puis on veut
protéger le fou c'est simple parce que
là il ya une vraie menace de jouer puis
on prend des 5
et puis ensuite cavalier prendrait le
fousseret en l'air exactement il y avait
une vraie menace effectivement de prises
au centre on protège des 5 et en plus on
cloue ici le cabba et ça c'est
intéressant aussi parce qu'on peut
menacer de jouer cavalier e 4 ici
attaquant encore une fois et pourtant
avec des échanges possibles alors tout
de suite ce serait sans doute pas une
bonne idée tout de suite puisque y
aurait la prise au centre le cavalier ne
défendant plus le pion des 5 à 3 alors
ça c'est bien facile tranquille à trois
menaces mais 4 pouces mais 4 gagne
potentiellement une pièce à ce si long
à ceci près que si on jouait tout de
suite il ya quand même la possibilité de
sacrifier le cavalier c6 sur b4 et oui
alors on va le voir tout de suite parce
que les noirs jouent ici tour 8 et blanc
pourrait se faire dire maintenant mais
quatre gagné une pièce alors pas tout à
fait il faut quand même toujours calculé
les variantes ici regardez si on joue
mais quatre autos maintenant maintenant
c'est trop tôt pourquoi parce qu'après
b4 simplement ont fait regarder cavale
et prendre les 4 et après et puis on
prend regardez vous prend et clouage
donc le cavalier prix etc avec on le
défend mais on peut pas il n'y a pas
beaucoup de deux coups là on peut en
tant que s'il faut 5 alors faut 5 c'est
bien cavaliers une carte et cabello 4
rajoute de la pression menace de prendre
donc il faut défendre maintenant sans
doute par la tour c1 est donc là on
défend bien puisqu'on a un deux trois
défenseurs avec le fou pour le cavalier
on a un deux trois attaquants ça suffit
pas mais c'est au nord de jouer f6 et le
fou n'a pas de gaz ou valve fou et là
aussi il paraît bien évidemment il ya
perte de la pièce ici comme en plus on
appris de bien on a un énorme avantage
si on bat en 5
on pousse encore aux 5 donc si on vend
des clubs pendant ici on pousse encore
le 5 et le fou doit partir ou se laisser
prendre
ce qui est très bon pour les noirs qu'on
fini leur développement le roi blanc n'a
pas finit toujours un clouage enfin ça
devient extrêmement pénible voilà donc
toutes les raisons qui font que il est
après tout 8 il est quand même trop tôt
pour posséder quatre mais c'est quand
une menace d'autant plus après le coup
malin de corse noé qui suit regardez il
va profiter de ce conte finalement un
peu faiblard même si ça mais bien sûr la
salle une tour en face du roi c'est
toujours bien mais il n'y a pas
d'ouverture immédiate et regarder et
quelques mieux pourtant il fait qu'à
valider de superbes alors c'est un très
bon coup qu'ils avaient des deux
pourquoi parce que maintenant ça m'agace
b4 parce qu'il n'y a plus de clouage on
est sûr n'est sur la diagonale
du roi sans compter qu'on pourrait même
venir en b1 pour protéger le cavaly donc
on a amené un défenseur supplémentaire
aux cavaliers dont il ya une vraie
menace des cadres donc en plus sur une
prise ici en c4 on peut envisager de
prendre avait le cavalier ans et quatre
attaquants la dame on gagne du temps
encore une fois sur la dame et si elle
d'un boulon rejoue dès 4 encore mais on
chasse le fou cette fois il n'ya pas
prise
il n'y a pas de gain de pièces mais il
ya quand même beaucoup de temps gagné
avec une avancée et une prise d' espace
très importante du côté dames
et puis il contrôle en plus la caisse de
quatre on avait vu que lecavalier 6 e
pouvait y sauter pour venir mettre de la
pression sur le cavalier ces trois là ça
ne sera plus possible
insight voilà donc c'est à dire mais les
deux de défendre voilà très subtil sokun
donc et regardent et il retarde au
maximum la sortie de ce fou puisque
aussi on peut envisager en cas de prise
de prendre aussi des fous pour pas
perdre de temps et continue et très vite
après le pote avec un petit roquet donc
voilà beaucoup de possibilités qui
rendent finalement les menaces noir un
peu signifiantes mai karkwa fait
continuer dans son idée c'est sans doute
une préparation d'ouverture qu'il a
essayé il joue cinq alors intéressant le
sec
regardez soutenu par là pour soutenu par
le cavalier site une poussée qui a été
préparé et sa chasse le fou f4 donc il
faut bouger sous quand je me le fais de
façon agressive
ils jouent ou g5 avec l'idée ici c'est
que ce cavalier peut venir au centre
faire des attaques
donc quand j'aurai voulu 5 à tout moment
il peut les changer tout de suite pour
les noirs c'est pas possible puisqu'il
ya déjà deux défenseurs ici quand on
reprendrait une première fois que tu me
prendrait la dame avec un gros avantage
mais comme c'est une possibilité en juin
rouge est simple en plus en plus on peut
menacer de casser le roc noir en
perturbant une écurie est là karpov se
lancer dans une attaque un peu olé olé
oui mais qui qui semble forte à première
vue le cas l'air très fort exactement
qui a l'air très forte qu'à valider 4 ça
s'est un peu classique givet et
cavaliers est en prise
on calcule même pas attention parce que
si on prend le cavalier alors on attaque
la dame dont ils réclament donc la
réaction immédiate c'est de se dire on
va prendre en d4
et dans ce cas là simplement ignorés
puis on prend échec et donc on va se
venger sur le cavalier c3 en ayant
ouvert les lignes avec donc un super jeu
donc ça c'est ce serait extrêmement
positif pour les noirs manque c'est hors
de question de faire cette manne sommes
sûrs qu'il a vu les d4 d'ouvrir ainsi
les in contre son propre droit en
rendant la pièce en ayant un centre
totalement ouvert aux quatre vents
donc porsche noël jouent le coup le plus
sage est très fort damned
or dans bien des intérêts mais je
m'enlève de la faute ici et en plus je
protège la poussée b4 d'autant plus cher
que là on prend même pas prendre une
première fois c'est à dire qu'il y aura
tout de suite une une perte et
et voilà donc là les noirs karpov joue
de façon extrêmement active et il
fallait que corse ne tienne compte de ça
dans sa manoeuvre il fallait calculer
ses coups puisqu'il joue faux f5
hélas ou heureusement qu'il ya un coût
encore pour les blancs parce que c'est
très fort attac la dame si la dame bouge
mais évidemment il ya cavaliers ans et
deux échecs
et puis le roi sera obligé de venir un
peu avec une catastrophe
le rock est cassé le fou ne peut pas
sortir on ouvrirait le show part
variable ce serait ça se terminerait en
quelques courts ça se terminerait en
quelques coups donc il faut absolument
qu'ils aient un coup ici de défense pour
les blancs heureusement il y en a il est
simple il est logique et naturelle et il
est efficace donc il a toutes les
caractéristiques du coup excellent c'est
fou détroit heureusement mais
heureusement qu est-ce que quand on
développe la dernière pièce et on parle
toute menace
karpov continue sans doute ce qui doit
être une préparation et ils jouent eux
4,4 alors là de quatre attaques le fou
certes mais sa bouche évidemment
l'action du fou est simple et en plus
long mais ça évite toute possibilité
d'ouvrir le jeu contre contre lorient ça
devient se lever un peu délicat puisque
le fou ici bouche la perte de la cour
est là sans doute
alors quand on ya joué le coup fouet ces
deux qu'on va voir tout de suite mais
sans doute ici peut-être que le kung fu
f1 est encore plus fort puisque
finalement on veut pas donner à ce
cavalier la possibilité de prendre le
fou on est les emprises et emprises
fausses ou quoi qu'il se laisse manger
soit qu'ils partent
et s'il part on a maintenant le temple
de jouer b4 voilà ou alors ou alors
qu'air france avait prévu de se laisser
manger le cavalier vente sur le seo 3
mais il ya le fou encore a donc
c'est pas terrible en fait donc oui je
sais pas trop ce qu aurait péri ce corps
est prévue serait très intéressant de
voir instaurée prévu car pop là-dessus
donc si lecavalier s'en va alors par
exemple réussissent pour attaquer le fou
pour pas perdre de temps on pourrait
envisager de prendre d'abord hafsi ce
plaisant 6 et maintenant regarder ont
simplement apprendre et le pion dessin
qu'on menace une fourchette sur le
moment on va très vite pouvoir jouer
fouet deux d'un coup de ici et rock
donc il n'ya pas de ne pas de vrai souci
maintenant pour les blancs donc faut
enfin qui est peut-être encore plus fort
que ce que jouer un corps je m'en mets
ici il joue poussée de 3,9 pouces et 2
alors l'avantagé évidemment c'est que on
garde la passivité du rock
alors que fo f1 mais retarde l et es
peur qu'au fond il ya la préparation
y'a pas d'ordinateur c'était pour gagner
il faut pas oublier ça c'est à dire que
les camps les joueurs pour leur
préparation ils né peuvent se baser que
sur leur propre jugement devant
l'échiquier et certainement pas sur ce
que préparent les ce que nous disent les
ordinateurs de
de combinaisons tactiques qui peuvent
calculer très vite il faut pas oublier
quand même même si là on à faire des
grands maîtres ont marqué l'histoire on
peut être aussi trompé par ses
impressions visuelles
si on montrait cette partie à des
centaines d'amateurs il aurait
l'impression que les noirs sont mieux
oui ça fait aucun semble faire aucun
doute
et par contre si on met ça dans une
contre 6,1 avons fait analyser par
l'ordinateur c'est pas si évident c'est
pas si évident tout à fait puis même
même pas on parlera même pas s'ils
continuent à jouer ça c'est qu'il avait
en fait il a déjà eu cette position très
probants sur mu à l'étude surnom donc
or ici donc karpov suis parent car il
prend ses deux échecs
donc là il faut reprendre notre problème
est maintenant bien il ya toujours la
menace les 4 que faire contre cette
menace et il ya aussi la manne à ce
fonds prend même si ce qui casse le
recueil nord ça fait quand même de deux
vraies menaces donc la carte pop joue un
coup parce malins qui permet de paris
les deux menaces aussi bien secousses
pas mal parce que moi j'aime bien ce
coup parce qu'il défend m6 il s'enlève
de la possibilité de b4 et en plus il a
un oeil sur ces 4 ce qui fait qu'il
soutient disparaît
et on peut par ok voilà donc il prend
quand même ici corps parce que quand je
dis si je prends maintenant bloqué mais
s'il prend avec la dame je suis plus
embêté sur cette diagonale en fait donc
d'un problème 6 2 karpov normal alors
pourquoi pas tout de suite qu'ils
avaient l'idée c'est un cahier pour les
soldes
et alors maintenant bien sûr on peut
jouer avec les blancs sans problème un
peu tentés cavaliers prend des singes
c'est tout à fait jouable alors le
problème maintenant qu'il peut avoir ces
dames j'ai cinq attaques g2 ce genre de
manoeuvre puisque en cas de rock il ya
le fameux classique fou h3 et pour
parler on est obligé de donner la
qualité il faut jouer chez trois et on
perd la tour donc voilà il veut pas il
veut pas rentrer là dedans tout de suite
qu il n'est pas pressé de roquettes ou
de suisse les parvenant menacé ici tout
ça est très solide donc il choisit un
coup intermédiaire il faut d'abord
cavalli b3 tout d'abord que l'arrivée 3
qui attaque ici le fou c'est simple je
cherchais la classe donc fou des six
normales de la part de de karpov
ils sont fous pourquoi on décide peine
parce qu'il veut avoir un petit oeil sur
le pillage de et le futur rock des
blancs mais là pour prendre les 5 et
problème pour les noirs parce que l'or
maintenant le problème c'est que alors
si on tente d'en manger sain c'est pas
une vraie menace parce qu'il ya le fou
des six qui est en prise si on tente
d'amener 6 on pourrait tenter d'amener 6
mars il semble que beaucoup voient la
date précise pour profiter du fait que
les blancs n'ont pas non par ok et si on
rock
maintenant on peut tenter fou h3 menace
ici de faire maths mais comme on a joué
d'abord qu'avaient les métros à regarder
la dame protège ici donc on peut tenter
simplement f4 je protège et je menace
tout reprend décide d'apprendre des six
pompes rend fou j'ai plus de fous pour
la tour et ça c'est un gros
ou même tour g5 qui attaquent la dame
encore plus fort et qui permettra de
ramasser mfou derrière exactement il ya
aussi tous que j'ai 5
la dame doit partir et le fouet perdu
donc f4 est très très fort et si les
blancs prennent henri iv qui semble un
coût tout à fait naturel regardez il ya
d'abord les changes de bain et on tourne
donc on gagne le fou exemple le fou est
perdu oui donc c'est très embêtant vous
le fou des six du reste m au choix
exactement donc après tout reprendre des
cinq cars pas officie ne joue pas le
ku'damm g6 peut-être quand même bon on
n'est pas obligé de le faire foi je
crois n'est rien et il joue plutôt en
scène mais là on peut faire un bilan
comme l'une des courses après non mais
les blancs n'ont pas ok puisqu'il va pas
entrer tout de suite mais là ici les
blancs quand même un clown est de plus
c'est à dire que toute cette manette
d'attac des noirs semblait fort qui me à
la fin
et bien pour éviter ces menaces de
pousser les quatre qui finalement se
s'avère extrêmement fort et n'ont été
obligé de donner un pion certes ils ont
un développement avancé puisque tout est
sorti quasiment rien que la torah 8 qui
est pas sorti les blancs encore le roi
au centre mais on voit qu'ici c'est très
difficile d'envisager des ouvertures on
peut pas casser cette muraille ici qui
est devant le pont noir d'autant plus
que le point 4 fait en fait office de
bouclier on peut parler faire et leur
blanc ne devrait pas trop tarder non
plus donc tours 5
et là encore on ne se presse pas et joue
cavalier des 4,4 alors très bien on
centralise toujours un pièce qui joue
pas on l'a centralise on attaque le fou
et funky nouvelles pièces pour les noirs
c'est un fou quand même l'intention pour
ces huit en échange ans le 5 et après
d'en prendre cinq cavaliers pro f 5 qui
prend le fou et d'emprunt 25 les blancs
termine par petit rock tranquillement
ils mettent le roi la brouille alors ici
il aurait pu quand même joué un coup
simple colloque évidemment cavaliers
prend le 4 on prend ce pion avec le
cavalier protégé par la dame et avait
pas de vrai risque en plus en protège le
pion c4 attaqué par la tour donc le sans
doute ici le meilleur coup était de
jouer ici calais prend 4 plutôt que le
coût de cornouaille mais quand je ne
veux pas à prendre de risques il est
dans une bonne position il a fini la
partie
bon il faut que les noirs à y prendre le
pion ses canons qu'après petit rock tour
prend ses 4 et bien les blancs jouent ce
besoin tour d1 avec une partie pour
l'instant assez facile il rend le pion
ayant l'option mais il s'appuie sur des
facteurs positionnelle il sa tour qui
occupe une importante colonne ouverte
attaque le fou il ya le pire des cas
très faible c'est l'heure ce pion ici
quand même des doit être défendue pour
l'instant par tour et dames si plus tard
le pion ici vient le défendre mais ça va
affaiblir le roi donc c'est un petit
facteur ici ce pion finalement un peu
faible un facteur positionnelle qui peut
être estimée à l'avantagé des blancs et
puis presque on fait tout de suite parce
qu'attention qu'il y en at il y en a du
couloir donc il faut quand même faire
attention quand on va défendre le
souffle donc d'armes cinq d'associer un
bon coup de grand maître puisque à la
fois je défends le fou mais en même
temps je crée une menace d'un proche
d'eux qui ne peut pas laisser faire
évidemment donc j'ai trois ans alors
karpov maintenant par le cou à 6 empêche
toute manoeuvre pourquoi pas des
cavaliers bcm porte à clé ou si la dame
prend en fait moins bien à tour ici un
tour je bête ne peut pas jouer les cinq
heures par contre parce que l'idée c'est
empêcher dame p 3 on ne peut empêcher
dam des trois ans joue en bo5
parce qu'effectivement de d'enlever
trois ici on peut pas jouer des cinq
puisqu'à cavaliers et
un petit protégé le pion veut prendre
donc à 6 et permet de pousser b5 sur la
plaque de la tour exactement à six en
cas d'un homme étrange oubli c'est
exactement la b3 quand même et b5
voilà tout est dit donc là maintenant
corse torreilles alors affaibli
s'est-elle d'un puisque des pions qui
avance sont faibles donc ça ça peut être
une petite faiblesse maintenant il ya ça
qui contre qui on peut jouer d'autant
que le coup à 4 et créer une vraie
menace heures on peut pas prendre
puisque la dame prendrait à tours on
peut pas prendre de la tour non plus
puisque cavaliers et protège donc sa
force quasiment le coup suivant pour des
cas très regardé ce que je côtoie une
facile pour lui
ils vous donnent des cinq centralisation
pouf pouf on a doublé sur la colombe et
on a toujours le problème d'espions cas
donc on n'a pas de soucis en cas de
prise ici de prendre le pion 4 de
l'autre côté
donc après d'en prendre des cinq tours
prendre des 5 et bien les noirs en un
souci sur ce pion ont un souci sur ce
pion en un souci sur ce pion en fait il
a réussi à faire des échanges en gardant
une position un petit peu supérieure et
tout temps tout en ne perdant pas de
temps parce qu'il crée à chaque fois il
ya toujours une menace
là c'est toujours ce sont toujours les
noirs qui sont un peu à la traîne qui
sont en train de le défendre et le
caroff est obligé de jouer fouet fuite
alors c'est ce qui a eu souvent après
une grosse initiative qu'on serait
contenté les noirs on a line satire 17e
parce qu'on sait mieux c'est pas
toujours mieux initiative c'est souvent
mieux mais pas toujours
puisque à la fin si on a donné un pion
pour l'initiative part ça ne peut ne pas
suffire comme on l'a vu là ça a permis
aux blancs après de finir leur
développement facilement d'avoir ce
micro avantage au centre ici il aurait
même pu jouer beaucoup plus précis sans
doute et à l'épreuve 1,4 mais un petit
avantage alors c'est pas un avantage
décisif mais un petit avantage qui
oblige les noirs maintenant à reculer
reculer reculer c'est à dire que là
c'est le contrecoup de cette initiative
un peu artificielle finalement qu'ils
ont développée donc fouet fuite et se
leurre pour apprendre des scènes à
prendre ah non il reprend pas et joue à
5 reprend pas parce qu'elles sont il y
aurait tout reprend alors évidemment si
les noirs ici
on reprenne en d5 je reprends de la tour
et j'ai une finale où je suis bien mieux
puisque j'ai un pion le plus et qui plus
est un pion passé alors sans compter que
ensuite je peux même venir
le cnct rabais le pion voilà ou choisir
de jouer tourbe et 8 pour clouer le fou
je voulais tenter une manoeuvre qui
avait lieu le 5 cavaliers cet échec
voilà je peux faire exactement mais
beaucoup de manoeuvre possible ici donc
à 5 de la part de kharkov plus malade
alors l'intérêt de la cei pour capreau
finalement c'est d'essayer de 10 rebonds
mais je vais me venger sur les pions b2
voilà mais en fait attention puisque
tours de 8
et voilà donc en échange de quoi ici non
seulement les noirs clou le fou ce qui
peu dangereux regardez la menace ses
cavaliers des cinq attaques latour
cavaliers 7 h 8 et tout reprend fou
matin donc ça va vite il faut parer tout
ça et des capots vous d'abord tout
reprendre les deux ce qui fait que sur
cavaler décès n'y a plus de prise de
tours là on a moins peur de câbles et
des cinq puisque on peut jouer
simplement le g6 et en cas d échec
simplement monde
mais qu'est ce que c'est ce qu'on avait
dit tout à l'heure en asie ce fameux
pions il est quand même un peu faibles
ils étaient un peu délicat donc après
tours à huit qui cette fois attaque le
pion à 5m 5 de karpov et forcé pour
protéger cette fois le pion au no 4 et
pour un petit peu libérés sont rois du
duc louwagie le centre alliés donc là et
ça n'empêche pas que l'on prend est
toujours un petit peu de retard
c'est ça quand on prend 1,5 qu'on a
maintenant récupéré le deuxième pire
donc on a un pur net de plus mais il
faut encore le transformer ceci dit
c'est un pion fort alors quelles sont
les possibilités pour karpov de défendre
cette position
on a quand même ici un fou contre en
cavalier ce qui est toujours bien parce
qu'un fou peut être à la fois défensif
et offensif
donc ici il peut quand même par exemple
en c5
il empêcherait à la fois à l'avancé du
pion b et il aurait un petit oeil
derniers mois même si ici c'est solide
mais si on n'arrive pas à passer là en
général on dit que pour gagner il faut
créer deux fronts parce que pendant que
l'adversaire est occupée d'un côté on
arrive à créer un sur plus de l'autre
donc ici alors fou b4 de la part de deux
corps de karpov alors une ans et pas
très gênant être une petite fourchette
mais il ya des coûts intermédiaires et
notamment le coup et chacun c'est simple
donc croire f7 et forcé il a simplement
cavaliers à 4 c'est bien c'est un bon
coup que la veille à 4 parce que ça
attaque la tour donc sa force
les noirs à jouer des coups forcé parce
que très vite tension est les menaces
vont vite b6 besset et on n'est plus
qu'à une casse de la promotion
ce qui serait un peu pénible donc tomber
un échec pour un g2 donc ça c'est pour
pas perdre de temps sur la tête du
cavalier et maintenant fou des six alors
vu qu'on peut pas aller en c5 maintenant
pour empêcher l'annoncé du pion on va en
d6 pourquoi pour avoir un oeil sur la
case une promotion b 8,1 malatia que si
le pion avant ça sera très dur quand
même pour les blancs d'aller au bout
parce qu'il va falloir contrôler deux
fois cette case tout en étant sous leur
prise de la tour dont c'est très
difficile d'avancer correctement
ici quand on essaie de jouer d'abord un
petit échec demander où va le roi et
aussi pour avoir un oeil sur ses pions
parce que parfois on peut peut-être
sacrifier ce pion pour en prendre deux
de l'autre côté c'est tout à fait
possible aussi donc 3 et 6 et
best-seller l'aura noté à le caler sur
blanc dans tout le bataclan par le fou
est par contre le curé sur noir donc il
pourrait être attaqué par le fou mais là
on ne peut pas ne peut pas aller assez
simple puisqu'elle cavaliers et on ne
peut pas aller mais sur un ses sept
puisque égale pions et à tous
donc c'est bien de dire qu'on peut
l'attaquer mais doux et si on sent là
bas on ne protège plus de 8 ce qui peut
être vrai souci donc fou de 8
on va carrément occuper la case si vous
pour dire ou blanc mais à toi de jouer
comment tu veux progresser parce qu'il
suffit pas d'avoir la possibilité de
encore faut-il pouvoir le faire donc
tour à 8.5
alors on reste toujours sur cette
diagonale contrôler la classe b mythe
est là alors là on profite comme
profitent de cette manne heures pour une
cour regardez c'est malin qui avait
laissé cinq jolies un coup qu'est
plusieurs fonctions la première c'est de
soutenir l'avancée du pion à laurent
soutiennent en menace bessette alors le
pion n'est plus protégé en apparence
c'est à dire que la tour noire en b1
peut prendre le purin b6 à ceci près que
s'exposerait à une fourchette on
s'expose à simplement cavaliers des sept
échecs rendement est bien sûr et attaque
la tour à noter que ça attaque aussi le
fou ce qu'il peut éventuellement être
utile parfois donc là on ne peut pas
apprendre le foot donc elle et ses cinq
food et si son attaque le cavalier mais
il baisse est quand même ah oui parce
que si maintenant fou prend cavaliers
ont fait dames et tout reprend dame tout
reprend dames on a une tour contrefout
en finale avec encore beaucoup de
pioncer gagner pour les blancs on passe
les détails mais il faut la jouer à la
wii mais sûr mais c'est une question de
technique c'est une question de
technique de patience aussi
il faut avancer heureusement aussi il
faut faire jouer laurent et c'est donc
ici
ben karpov va essayer d'améliorer sa
position défensive il sait bien qu'il
s'en défende monsieur c'est pas possible
pour lui blanc parce qu'on peut pas vous
aider si c'est un coin de la perte du
pion et puis si on veut emmener le
cavalier à la protection on défend plus
bessette
vous voyez que c'est pas ça ne suffit
pas de mais on voit que on n'a pas de
crainte de laisser au carillon prise a
connu il ya des coupures dame il ya
quand même là une manoeuvre très
concrète des blancs ce serait de faire
échec avec lecavalier en 17
ab oui il a tout de suite à une menace
mais sur imaginons que les noirs dit bon
je peux la coke et je vais pas tacler le
fou j'attaque avait la tour avec l'idée
que maintenant je menace tout reprend et
j'ai toujours le fou que je peux donner
contre le pion on peut même faire
promotion tout de suite on peut faire en
promotion quand même dalle et surtout
prend dame pour prendre pour prendre une
personne car ils prendront tour prend
des parts dont on ferait échec sans
doute et après ici simplement apprendre
du cavalier on a une pièce de plus il
faut le faire dans le bonheur
oui il faut s'attendre à en rêver sinon
on est tout de suite un peu embêté donc
ici bessette recettes
voilà donc c'est bien parce qu'ils
ramènent le moment approche du pion donc
ça c'est important
et aussi
il s'enlève des possibilités d'échec
alors regardez la subtilité notamment de
cochonneries joue d'abord touché 8
alors ça c'est bien ils attaquent depuis
angers 7 avait l'idée que si mam et
n'ont même pas on pourrait faire de
toute façon plutôt devrait on faire mon
as tu de notre projet 7 on ne peut pas
prendre mes 16 ans donnera toujours par
à cause de l'internet augusta donc ici
fou aux 5 alors mais le problème c'est
que ça crée même pas de menaces pour
venir là parce qu'il ya toujours dame
mais on sait qu'on protège le pian
d'accord hélas alors qu'en retenant il
se sait ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
on peut pas gagner avec un seul franc
donc il ouvre un deuxième front et en
créant simplement en forçant karpov à
ouvrir le jeu par f4 attaque le fou mais
je peux en train de réfléchir une
variante ces attaques le fou le fou ne
peut pas protéger à la fois des 8es g7
il faut empêcher de faire dame donc il
faut jouer par exemple foulée 6 et je
prends g7 avec échec et après je
ramassais ou alors je reviens au g8
puisque je peux toujours proposé de
faire dame etc
donc je récupère un pion ce qui fait que
si je récupère un pur l'autre côté je
peux même envisager d'échanger les tours
avec cette fois cavalier contre fou mais
un point de plus et une partie gagnante
aussi alors à noter qu'ici sur f4 on
peut prendre un f3
j'étais en train de me dire mais qu'est
ce qui se passe il fait d'abord échec
puis qui prend un f3 mais non on ne peut
pas parce que là paris dans patients ne
se faire d'abord tout de suite
et ici on fait échec que laura bush on
n'a pas le droit de faire la prise en
patient après mais voilà donc le
problème de la double défense se pose
sur gaza mais c'est le genre de truc on
peut avoir ce maillot une donc pu rompre
avec trois échecs ça s'arrange les
blancs de toute façon puisque maintenant
le roi va pouvoir s'activer se rapproche
du centre mais ses forces et de ses
forces et ses frises le coup de corne de
force ce coup on n'a pas le choix donc
roi prend et maintenant on a ouvert un
deuxième front parce que tout de suite
le roi de vie actif
alors qui
n'était pas là donc si ce fou
bush on peut envisager de monter un f4
par exemple sur le chemin on peut aussi
envisager d'amener le roi par d'autres
chemins
on peut aussi envisager de créer un
front en bougeant les pions pourquoi pas
sur l'autre côté mais en tout cas on
peut être actif de ce côté là pendant
que les noirs sont vissés à la défense
de ce plan de promotion donc cette
partie elle et elle est vraiment
standard pour bien comprendre comment
gagner des finales avec un pion de l'ale
en plus il faut ne faut pas mettre
toutes ses forces du côté de lui il faut
aussi créer des menaces de l'autre côté
et inversement quand on défend mais il
faut éviter d'avoir des menaces de trous
de côté différentes bon donc croire
cette montée repos face on ne peut pas à
vendre ses récents moins costauds tam
donc il vient attaquer la cour ce qui
oblige à tour à revenir
louis assez vite c'est très bien et hop
il et c'est bien car peaufine il attend
un de toute façon il peut rien faire il
est un peu un peu coincé alors focaux
branchement il démontre maintenant qu'il
peut forcer le gamin parce qu'il suffit
pas d'être en position supérieure il
faut trouver sinon ça sera parti du wii
donc h3 alors il met les pieds ont
regardé sur la couleur opposée de celle
du fou et il veut sans doute joué au
théâtre et affaiblir encore plus les
pions et les cases ennemis à 100
on comprend bien le coup de karpov qui
suit up dont j'ai milite pour les huit
petites manoeuvres à noter que
maintenant sur 3 e set on peut faire
échec
pourquoi pas attaquants latour défendant
le pion bessette ce qui peut libérer le
kavé ça peut être intéressant puisque ce
cavalier il a peut-être envie de bouger
d'attaquer les fous de se recycler sur
des casques en f4 d'aller ou alors
peut-être d'aller viser cette case
pourquoi pas s'il peut aller sur cette
case pour contrôler la classe de
promotion tout cas ça peut être une
manoeuvre possible après j'ai 5
attention on assez les noirs qui
essaient d'empêcher le roi blanc
finalement de monter c'est pas tellement
une attaque pour les noirs ils sentent
bien qu'ils sont en infériorité ici leur
pièce là ne doivent être à la défense
mais c'est pour empêcher le roi d'avoir
des velléités pour passer il pourrait y
avoir une petite manoeuvre sur g5 là il
pourrait y avoir une petite manoeuvre
ensuite des noirs ce serait de jouer
tour b2 pour fermer la porte
oui et g4 qui mène au matin oui on sait
jamais voilà il ya toujours des petits
pièges comme ça au final c'est un petit
piège m6 a effectivement oui tu sur ton
bde on peut menacer matt bon c'est
facile appareils ont toujours eu 4 1
peut jouer ce genre de choses mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut en tenir compte et il
n'en tient compte puisqu'il joue g4
alors j'ai cas pourquoi regarder
toujours pareil on a le foot la semaine
donc on a envie de casser les classes
blanche parce que le roi il aime bien se
promener sur les cases manche puisqu'il
n'est pas attaqué par le foot et en plus
on attaquera le ce pion là qui peut
difficilement défendue par le fou
d'autant plus que bien
la défense de toujours de la classe b 8
donc je prends g4 je pense à 4 et 3
cette attaque
la tour 8 donc je milite encore
maintenant que la menace est de prendre
le pion g5 et sproxy quatre voix proche
des 4 097 alors là on peut se poser la
question qu'est ce qui se passe surtout
reprendre g5 se serait sans doute une
erreur puisque après tout reprend g5
simplement on pourrait jouer fou des
ciels 6 et ovales cavaliers et s'il
croyait douce et le pion 17 qui est pris
imaginons une variante comme fou des six
cavaliers par exemple le quatre attaques
le fou ça laisse un peu de répit mais
simplement fou et c'est là tout est
attaqué et j'ai pas moyen d'aller
défendre lampions donc ça serait une
erreur et je perdrais mon puits en
avance beaucoup plus dur à gagner ça oui
sur l'année à blanc coran mais c'est dur
il ya toujours un petit avantage mais il
a fondu mais c'est dur parce que là on
peut dans cette position peut sacrifier
le fou contre le pion et après tour
cavaliers contre tours ces parties
nulles
il faut le savoir maintenant on va
évidemment raté le gain donc au fc tours
c8 donc il rentre pas là dedans ils
gardent l'avantagé ici n'est pas pressé
puisqu'il ya pression rien pour ces huit
donc fou des six de l'appartement mais
continuent à faire tranquille pour ce
noël ne prend même pas la peine de
prendre le pion gsm
il continue son avancée ici toujours
pareil on peut toujours pas prendre le
cavalier à cause de dames
donc si tours j'ai un échec bref 5
alors si on refait tout richesse
comprendre qu'ils ont donc g41 carpeaux
maintenant se dit ben tant pis je fais
g4 avec l'idée de se dire que s'il est
blanc pousse en bien 8
je sacrifie le fou crise prises et avec
mon pions passé je peux peut-être forcé
les blancs à rendre la pièce et je peux
rentrer d'un final tour et tour contre
pions
et ce sera plus simple et c'est plus
simple et même vu que les rois sont pas
coupés ça peut même être nul de façon
forcée
donc il joue au foot le capot failli se
laisse pas faire donc regarder c'est
très joli ce que fait correctement et
peace corps tu me joue le magnifique ou
eu 5 voilà il se laisse pas prendre au
piège de jouer b8 et de rentrer au final
pas clairement joué 5
l'idée de 5 elle est simple c'est de
dire où elles font parce que le fou ici
n'a pas de case et il va là où là il est
perdu et le pion reste reste là pour
faire dame
donc si ce fou ne peut plus protéger la
dame et bien on va faire dame et la dame
là par contre elle va ramasser tout le
matériel donc eu cinq échecs très bien
et ont regardé fallait bien calculer un
parce que ça les embête ans comme sosie
surtout revue les options échec 5 qui va
être deux fois aux prises alors je vais
ou alors déjà par exemple je n'ai pas en
d4 parce qu'un des cas de fou prend
échec et je continue à protéger 2008 et
en plus j'ai même pu repasser mais se
sait jamais ce qui peut se passer
je suis même pas sûr que les noirs gagne
pas cette finale non non il faut être
précis il faut jouer roi des sec et
l'art des cinq jeux menace à la fois de
faire reprend et aussi de faire pression
de fer puis on prend voilà aussi tout
reprend je vous fais trois points fou
est ici alors il reste la possibilité
pour l'honneur de faire un fou prend ici
ça paraît normal faut prendre oui et là
regardez up
quel magnifique avec échec en plus est
si bien sûr on peut jouer la tour mais
si on prend le fou je vous rappelle
qu'il ya d'année c'est donc et en plus
si la tour vient en b1 j'ai pas le temps
parce que ses échecs
donc oui donc
voyez ces malades aura des 5 on peut pas
prendre en fait ni avec le fou à cause
de la fourchette en d3 n'y avait la tour
à cause de quoi rendre fou donc il reste
que tourner un tour d un échec
l'on se demande un petit peu comme
encore choix il va éviter
et oui parce que j'en ai tellement
regardé si si l'on revient en c6 ou
combien mais si c'est pas grave on prend
le pion le sait bien sûr on va perdre le
fou à cause de la dame mais mais mais on
a un pion ici d'abord celle qui peut
aller à dame
et puis surtout s'il est éliminé qu'on
allume une foule plus que tour cavaliers
donc s'il ya aucun souci ces parties
nulles donc là on se dit mais oui mais
finalement il n'a réussi à s'en sortir
karpov là parce que si je suis obligé de
revenir là encore est cher très cher
encore échec donc ça va être partie
nulle part et chez perpétuel et si les
blancs sorte de saba et c'est eux qui
risquent perdre que faire bah oui que
faire faites vous la main oui c'est ça
c'est là c'est très subtil
c'est ce qu'on appelle un sacrifice
silencieux ouais même si c'est très beau
khalid 3 c'est assez paradoxal qui a été
3 alors la question pour le fou se pose
toujours si je prends ici je parle pas
on dira je retrouve du cabinet puisque
du cloud et je peux pas garder le fou là
puisque toutes ses classes sont prises
puisque je suis obligé de prendre le
cavalier avec la tour mais ça a l'air
bien tour échec mais
oui mais en fait non à cause de race et
quatre abandons
c'est énorme c'est incroyable et là y'a
plus rien à faire puisque le fou alors
regardez la suite c'est que mais là tout
est attaqué par le roi et le fou est
attaquée je vous rappelle l'importance
du fou on avait des gésiers à noter
qu'on peut pas les attaquer le pion non
parce qu'on a toujours le ca admettant
que les noirs face fonds prend puisqu'il
ya que ça qui reste 3 prend d'ailleurs à
prendre
et en cas de dame ici alors pardon la
séance et aux morts de jouer donc une
ici par exemple j'ai trois ont fait dame
bien sûr sans problème et après il faut
prendre tout reprend ben y'a pas pour
ceux qui ont pu aller à dame il suffit
de ramener un tour ici est un programme
le roi en mai ils ont ramassé tour et
roanne
enfin c'est fini pour faire échec et mat
assez facilement contre le roi voilà
donc ces magnifiques suroît c4 à la fin
de la de la brillante autre possibilité
quelles sont mes devoirs fou prend
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire d'autre
tu peux rien que voulait faire d'autre
le problème de la ici c'est que alors si
si si si si si on fait j'ai trois
peut-être j'ai droit au g2 on peut
essayer ça alors l'admettons j'ai trois
roues apprend alors on prend d'abord le
fou mais on râle et on a dit qu'on
prenait le fou parce qu'ayant vous
regarde avec les mains tenant on peut
faire j'ai deux camps même en disant
d'am-dam simplement je fais dame bien
sûr regardé leur faut savoir le faire
d'am dam et la regarder le problème
c'est que c'est vite maths parce que
c'est aux blindes jouer le problème de
ce type de dames c'est que c'est le
premier qui fait chier qui gagne
regardez tour échec aurait eu six tours
sète où on est c'est assez rapide pour
cet échec
regardez je protège avec madame ici le
pion et le roi ne peut pas venir ici non
plus à iai donc je suis obligé de
rentrer dans le fameux match matt de
l'escalier le mat de l'escalier
classique en regard des échecs
je peux essayer de monter initie un
échec ça va moi je n'ai pas le temps de
faire ce qu'il faut pour amener la tour
voilà il faut pas traîner il faut pas ce
qu'il faut faire et c'est tout le temps
parce que oui si vous prenez la tour
vous pouvez mais vous risquez vous
retrouvez un échec perpétuelle c'est à
dire que la dame faire des déchets
partout donc il faut au contraire
formaté donc voilà
c'est c'est pas toutes les défenses
tombent magnifique abandon car pas
officielle oui c'est là qu'on voit les
grands maîtres abandonne au bond oui oui
vous là ça servirait à rien de
poursuivre la torture parce que c'est le
supplice de tantale les noirs pourraient
presque tous prendre mais ils peuvent
rien prendre finalement et ils ont quand
même eu un cavalier gratuitement qui
leur sert à rien puisque c'est l'effet
perdre c'est le coup cavaliers detroit
est assez incroyable magnifique où il
fallait voir dans la combinaison finale
alors qu'approchait mieux messieurs
cornu emieux messieurs mais il faut voir
ce type de combinaisons pour finir parce
que sinon ça peut durer longtemps hélas
aurait pu se terminer par par là nul que
ce qu'on voit difficilement quand je
croyais pouvoir éviter la répétition de
coups s'il n'y a pas ce sacrifice
extraordinaire
voilà donc on a tous vu ses ventes
finales modèle attaque d'un côté
création de nouveaux francs de l'autre
et déstabilisation finale avec une
combinaison il faut il faut pas croire
que ça vient tout seul le fruit mûrit
pas tout seul il faut l'aider un peu
voilà sur cette victoire de cornouaille
face à kharkov en 78 sur cette partie et
pas sur le match malheureusement pour
lui puisqu'il a fini par perdre le match
nous finissons cette émission spéciale
kornoi sur la carrière donc de ce très
grand champion merci jérôme merci
stéphane et puis moi je vous dis donc à
bientôt pour une nouvelle émission
diagonale tv sur l'histoire des grands
champions ou d'autres ses missions ou
aux transmissions au revoir au revoir